well my first reaction was I was
absolutely just too old and the reason
why they said that my views don't matter
when it does
because I'm someone who has dancing game
why did you want to bring the the
challenge in the first place why do you
want that law changed how does it make
you feel the fact that that is law it
makes me feel like the eyes the eyes
didn't be here but it should be extinct
I know there's not two but um that's how
it makes me feel and the other day when
I was holding my nappy ribbon in Mexico
I was
flabbergasted that the law protects him
and not me
and what will you do now will you will
you appeal again to take the case to the
court of the Supreme Court yes we're
going to the Supreme Court and then
hopefully practice my friends
you're not giving up nope and and in the
Judgment there as I just mentioned the
the the judge said that this this
question of whether it should be lawful
this part of the law is not one for the
courts it's a question for Parliament I
mean at least perhaps you can answer
this what what's your message to MPS
will he take it to start a campaign it's
obviously be discussing everything with
our solicitor we're sorry with Heidi's
solicitor
um and we'll go to the Supreme Court but
if we um an MP would like to take the
case up we're more than happy to meet
them and get on with it um work with
anybody that would have to get the law
changed that's the best way to do it
that's the way we'll do it
and how do you feel what's your reaction
to today's ruling just um absolutely
devastated that the people can think
um that right up into the moment of
birth
a baby with a disability can be born
even though five minutes later after
birth they have all the protection of
any other person but in the in the womb
they have no protection
and my my second payments can't be here
today but when she was thinking with her
son she wasn't told repeatedly to have
one but as he said to have have an
abortion yeah well if he says in her
nose not color she said she did modern
divorce yeah and they still kept on
so they're trying to persuade her to
have an abortion this week yeah at 30
started against that